[Música]
la economía en directo américa de france
24 y ya está conmigo el estudio el
abismo de zúrich y lis bienvenido muy
buena mañana del lunes nuevamente vamos
a iniciar entonces con los temores que
hay en europa en torno a la posible
crisis energética así es raúl temores
que se incrementaron luego del anuncio
de rusia de una suspensión de tres días
en el suministro de gas hacia europa a
través del gasoducto nord stream 1 a
finales de este mes por ello la moneda
oficial estamos hablando del euro moneda
que este curso legal en 19 de los 27
países de la unión europea se cotizó en
mínimos de cinco semanas en medio de
toda esta situación a 09 euros por dólar
en el inicio de las operaciones
semanales el incremento de los temores
de una posible recesión en parte por los
problemas de suministro de energía en
europa y en especial en la unión europea
serán café que han generado toda esta
situación debido a que una interrupción
de gas ruso por parte de respuesta a las
sanciones tras la invasión a ucrania ha
generado un impacto dentro de la
economía impacto que por supuesto se
acrecentó este lunes tras un informe del
boom de españa que revela la posibilidad
de una recesión porque podría la
inflación alcanzar máximos de 10 por
ciento en el mes este para el periodo de
otoño alemania se encuentra entre las
naciones más vulnerables a cualquier
corte de suministro de energía y los
costos altos que están presentando la
producción en los actuales momentos por
su parte en españa' representantes del
gobierno esperan el máximo apoyo para el
decreto de ahorro energético al tiempo
que en bélgica está creciendo la demanda
de compra de energía empresas pequeñas o
cooperativas que producen electricidad a
través de fuentes renovables
louis cambiamos de información porque
uno de los más grandes puertos del reino
unido se está viendo afectado por la
mayor huelga en 20 años en 30 años raúl
estamos hablando de philips tours donde
al menos mil 900 trabajadores decidieron
paralizar sus actividades por un período
de ocho días para precio entre otras
cosas por mejores salarios la presión de
los trabajadores responde al incremento
de la inflación que se ubicó por encima
del 10% la semana pasada de hecho los
trabajadores ya rechazaron una propuesta
de 7% al ubicarse está por debajo del
índice de precios al consumidor unas dos
mil quinientos cincuenta personas
trabajan en el puerto de péric son el
más activo del país que maneja alrededor
de 48 por ciento del comercio de
contenedores en reino unido a la acción
se presenta luego de que trabajadores
del tren de londres protagonizaron una
huelga el pasado 19 de agosto y se está
a la espera de otra huelga de los
trabajadores del correo para el 26 de
este mes por escuchamos que dijeron
algunos representantes del principal
sindicato durante la manifestación
no tiene nada que ver con una estrategia
nacional es algo que ha sucedido aquí a
nivel local y refleja lo que está
sucediendo en otros lugares la gente de
todo el país se siente de la misma
manera parece estar coordinado porque la
gente siente lo mismo y llega a la misma
conclusión es suficiente
hasta francia porque este país que
estudia limitar los vuelos en aviones
privados así es una medida que fue dada
a conocer por el ministro de transporte
y se centra en los esfuerzos para luchar
contra el cambio climático y además
reducir el consumo de energía así lo
recoge el diario francés le parisien
a través del cual el ministro señaló que
pretende elevar esta propuesta a nivel
europeo para que sea una medida de mayor
eficacia según el rotativo el gobierno
francés se trabaja desde julio en un
plan para actuar y regular los vuelos
entre privados en el marco de las
iniciativas dirigidas a mitigar el
impacto de la crisis energética el
ministro de transportes quiere plantear
la cuestión a la vuelta de las
vacaciones de verano cuando el ejecutivo
de manuel macro no discute el plan
sobriedad a la batería de medidas que
busca cumplir con los objetivos de
ahorro energético requeridos por la
unión europea para afrontar la escalada
en los precios del gas tras la guerra en
tucker nos vamos a china gris porque las
autoridades siguen aplicando políticas
para estimular la economía así es raúl y
en este sentido el banco central recortó
la tasa de préstamos hipotecarios por
segundo en este año la medida busca
luchar contra una crisis de liquidez en
el sector inmobiliario la tasa de
interés preferencial de los préstamos a
5 años se redujo de 4 45 por ciento a un
4 3% igualando la reducción récord
realizada en el mes de mayo por su parte
la tasa de interés preferencial para
préstamos a un año una referencia por lo
que son los préstamos empresas se redujo
de 3 7% a un 3
65% los movimientos sugieren que el
banco popular de china está preocupado
por los problemas en el mercado
inmobiliario ya el mes pasado había
anunciado a los bancos que rescataran a
los promotores inmobiliarios en apuros
para completar proyectos de vivienda sin
terminar y así evitar una creciente
huelga hipotecaria que amenaza con dañar
gravemente la economía bueno louis
fallamos hablar decir lanka porque se
dieron a conocer los datos inflación en
ese país y de acuerdo con el
departamento de estadísticas de esa
nación el índice nacional de precios al
consumidor subió un 66 7% interanual en
julio después de registrar un aumento de
58 9% en el mes
está de acuerdo con el organismo
representa la inflación más alta a nivel
de precios minoristas en toda la nación
se espera que la inflación aumente en
agosto después de que blanca revise las
tarifas eléctricas el banco central dijo
este mes es que el ritmo de inflación se
estaba disminuyendo pero aún podría
llegar a un 60 o 65 por ciento y
probablemente alcanzar su máximo punto
en el mes de septiembre seguimos
hablando de inflación pero en argentina
porque sigue golpeando los bolsillos de
todos los ciudadanos de ese país lista
si es raúl hay que recordar que este
indicador se ubicó en 6,3 por ciento a
nivel mensual en el mes de julio y todos
los análisis apuntan a que podría
ubicarse sobre los seis puntos
porcentuales para el mes de agosto y un
trabajo realizado por la firma el sg y
que expone el diario 'ambito financiero'
revela que durante la tercera semana del
mes de agosto el precio de los alimentos
registró un aumento de 12 puntos
porcentuales para ubicarse con un alza
de 1 9% indicando así que en tres
semanas el precio de los alimentos
registra 5 por ciento durante el mes de
agosto y cadáveres económicos
las acciones de los globales y también
los futuros de wall street cayeron el
lunes mientras los inversionistas miran
hacia la conferencia en la reserva
federal de esta semana que busca señales
sobre posibles aumentos en la tasa de
interés en eeuu todo ello para controlar
la inflación en este sentido en los
mercados asiáticos cerraron con números
mixtos tokio y hong kong bajaron sus
ganancias al tiempo que shanghai fue el
único mercado que avanzó o reportó
ganancias a lo largo de la jornada esto
precisamente por el anuncio del banco
central de china de disminuir el la tasa
de interés para las hipotéticas rey
hipotecas los precios del petróleo que
ayer más de 15 dólares por barril del
tiempo que en europa los mercados de
londres y frankfurt abrieron a la baja y
están operando con números negativos la
jornada para finalizar dije este último
bloque económico de nuestra mañana cifra
el día tiene que ver con los 75 millones
de dólares que es el valor que tiene un
yate de un magnate ruso que será
subastado este día martes este buque o
este barco fue en gibraltar el pasado
mes de marzo después de que el banco
estadounidense jpmorgan afirmara que su
propietario no pudo pagar un préstamo de
unos 20 millones de dólares gracias como
siempre por toda la información o louis
nos vamos mañana con más economía
pasamos a saludar humanizada que tiene
toda la actualización de los deportes